we're here with the official Joker
character breakdown from injustice - now
this was taken from nether realms
livestream but since the game comes out
next Tuesday May 16th
be sure to hit that subscribe button to
stay up to date with all the latest on
DC's premier fighting game
alright so Joker retained most of his
normal attacks there pretty much factor
they're pretty much unchanged one change
I'd like to go over is does everyone
remember his back one foot see if that
actually is ko yeah it's actually called
footsie and this people have been asking
footsies are back so all those have been
canine oh jeez that would dominated
footsies are back this is it
you have no excuse right there buddy
Joker yeah and you would probably buy
the original I'll like the original
it'll actually come out on whip so you
can whip it and then do this very strong
technic yeah bit of that you do not have
good foot sees you know but his big
changes in this special boobs those have
gone through a punchy so let's go over
those first off in the original he has
gunshot which is actually very fast good
recovery but it didn't have a meter he
now has a meter burn where the bane flag
comes out and then livable and pop up
and you can actually do combos with it
it's a combo starter you can use it up
close
it's not with one okay you can come on
now if you delay a little bit oh yeah
there that is even going off the rails
here Steve with the Humber Sangha yeah
where's our Joker Flair the word so
that's actually compost yeah it is often
this stopped right okay
all right we get it it it works because
for people who are good at Joker all
right another change is to his craze run
so he has this crowbar bag it's filling
over that it's still very fast but now
you can actually do a full screen it'll
start running which is I've seen this a
million times that's still a great the
way did the way Heinie's yeah all the
way there and now the big thing is once
he goes through the run this actually
turns into an unblockable so it is
completely overwhelmed and then he can
actually meet her burn it to get armor
so she could try to do you Lizzie has
Dizzy's here I'm available
okay yes he's available to play and she
try to like do her she'll toss oh where
does my great matches here later was a
mistake Janet listen to it in a visiting
me to burn it to get armor you get a
meter bridge later and get the full
damage if you want to use two bombs so
you can use two bars on one special move
you can that's crazy crazy oh yeah
another changes he has a brand new pair
he now uses the joy buzzer and
electrocute them and not the full screen
and I love the meter burn this does
additional damage and looks amazing and
keeps them standing
do this in the corner the advantage you
can go back to your zoning with your gun
shop secondly his character power has
been redone he used to have to do a
parry and then he got his hot now you
could just laugh so this is level 1 and
this increases is go building his dashes
is jumping everything this gets faster
you can go to level 2 and you can see it
drain so he's got to keep it up and then
you can go all the way to level 4 kind
of using it like Bane to like put the
next one up when that last one goes down
that sort of idea and then you can do
this stuff look at this
now can you refresh it when you're at
maximum you can and that's the
interesting thing you can actually keep
it going indefinitely as long as you're
laughing now it will start to decay and
you'll get less time the more you do it
right but he can keep it up indefinitely
if he wants he does have to go through
the recovery so the opponent's gonna
have to guess is you're going to go for
it and then you can do your shield toss
and beat up or you can just go in where
I start going crazy
who's gonna anti whose the entire knees
right no one say ran out Yeah right
right yeah this is not look at this so
so you I guess one of the things you
know the people talked about for
injustice 1 is this that getting to
level 3 by using a parent they have
taken too much time it was too hard and
now you can just go into it all time so
I can you know another issue too is that
the fact that now with our new training
mode you can actually set up people's
character powers but that you can
practice with Joker at full laughs so
let's see is through because it's pretty
great
and how about a super do it and he still
has this chattering teeth I forgot about
that that's still there and that's the
key to his setups you know you put him
on the ground then you start playing a
game and especially in crow barns good
all that gets you kicked into Brainiac
get you to the ready all right so you
won't see some loadouts I do oh yeah
some amazing here and I actually I don't
remember what you set up so this is
going to be new to me tip right there
cool I I've sort of themed them in a way
ok I appreciate that also this is this
is sort of your your dapper I'm more
British sort of Joker I like it with
dynamite strapped to his stomach well I
mean right still Joker yeah so the first
one we gave them is crowbar fling which
is a new projectile mm-hmm very Vega and
this is awesome it's mid hitting when it
hits they're staggered it has a ton of
block stun it's very basically a very
good screen control move and it looks
amazing I love the reaction on the other
character yes I absolutely I love the
weight he puts into it and their
reaction literally seeing stars yep and
then we gave him surprise where he kicks
the president cautiously and you can do
close medium or far and this kind of
replaces the chattering team but it's a
farther chattering teeth I love that
Joker's making you laugh so much
oh the confetti just killed better
that's happened
that's so great so he gets a combo when
that hits with that we are all living it
so surprised and you can see it's very
very fast great speed control so you
know you're using a gun and then you get
this bad boy out and then they're gonna
have to respect it or they're going to
get body by that confetti and I just
princess diet if the mascara getting
this equipment confetti present it's
just it's so very much for you I don't
think they have confetti anti mascara
they don't have parties what is this
demonic paper itch
Steve four-minute hug to the next load
out so excellent I'm excited I haven't
even seen this one you haven't ahem this
one is rip reporter Joker oh that's not
I really like to have yeah this is like
1940 style reporter right it's like he
killed Clark Kent and took his identity
daddy goes I didn't go down what's the
lore but yeah sure that's probably it so
on this Laura we focused on combo
ability I gave them two abilities that
enhances combos so number one throws
typically are a low reward option they
open you up and they don't do a lot of
people if you actually can read or burn
his throat and then you can go back
three or four three or something
let's just go down to let's go yeah yeah
it works Steve I don't want to gets all
that all the crap for not being able to
complete combos and it's it turns out
it's you
well I'm sorry I'm not a joker me all
right
we're also look at that there's a cop
that's a combo that is indeed a combo so
this makes us throw that much better you
know we talked about earlier you can
have the chattering T down and then you
go for a throw or you can put the
present or the opponent is scared to
move because their preys run they go in
for the throne normally you're getting
up 12% you the mentality is Oh throw me
I don't care you will care yeah you will
care and then another enhancement is the
crazy part it enhances the meter burn
and again he gets a pop up so all of a
sudden his overheads it goes full screen
it is unblockable you talk about you
know using two bars we can undo that hit
a combo so that move becomes absolutely
overwhelming with this with this he's
getting a huge reward for his praise one
all right and that just tongue even
increases his uh his overwhelming play
style I'll do when he gets going it's
going to be very very hard to stop
loving so that is the judge or Joker
yeah I think um what was good about him
is back and I think his new tools are
really really powerful and may help him
a lot they helped him in the original
Joker was considered to be one of the
weaker characters in the tournament
scene but it's not because he didn't
have good tools a lot of great players
recognized in his setups when he got you
in the corner you were in serious
trouble but and now his kind of mid ring
range game has been helped out and he
still maintains what made him good so
it's all it's a lot like green arrow or
a character where we kind of build on
what made him good and he should be a
lot stronger and a lot more fun to play
this time excellent
so real quick let's talk about a couple
things where we get some fights going
here there I mean you people tweet a lot
like